la parole est à monsieur gérard manuel
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues
monsieur le premier ministre la
situation agricole est très préoccupante
à l'heure où les éleveurs entre leur
fourrage à l'heure où la moisson se fait
le moral des agriculteurs ainsi que
celui des éleveurs est au plus bas et
leur ressenti se situe entre résignation
et colère
le monde paysan est au bord de la
rupture que leur répondez vous si ce
n'est que votre ministre de la culture a
présidé une table ronde pour définir un
accord il n'est toujours pas appliquée
que vous êtes vous et qu'avez vous à
dire aux producteurs de lait qui ont vu
leurs prix baisser de 13% un an
monsieur le prévenu premier ministre
haché khalid de lait à la ferme vaut
moins cher aujourd'hui qu'une seule
cigarette
que répondez vous que faites-vous pour
l'éleveur de porcs à trésorerie exemple
et qui subit une perte d'exploitation de
50 mille cinq cent mille euros depuis un
an et dont les prix au kilo en baissé de
17% connaît de lui aussi producteur de
blé dans les prix ont chuté de 14% avec
des charges de plus en plus lourdes avec
des contraintes de production de plus en
plus pénalisante par rapport à nos
voisins c'est toute l'agriculture mais
aussi l'ensemble du monde rural qui est
en danger celle de votre responsabilité
mais ce premier ministre de faire
respecter l'accord du 17 juin d'alléger
les charges de production et de revenir
sur un certain nombre de contraintes
mises en oeuvre par une mini station
française qui on ajoute sans cesse à
celle imposée par l'union européenne est
engagée de suite engagé de suite des
mesures de soutien aux trésoreries ce
premier ministre c'est en agissant sur
ces points que vous libérer les énergies
d'une profession prisonnière des carcans
administratifs et financiers
je vous le redis la situation est très
grave nombreux agriculteurs et éleveurs
sont dans le rouge et sont en situation
de détresse
quand allez-vous agir merci la parole et
à monsieur jean marie le guen mini
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député il vous plaît à mort
il voudrait bien aller
excusez mon collègue le foll des
journées avec le président mexicain à
marseille dans un voyage d'état et il
est bien normal qu'il soit là et je le
sais parce qu'il ne vous aviez un mot
tout à l'heure c'est aussi pour défendre
la filière de l'agroalimentaire
vis-à-vis de marchés à l'extérieur et au
mexique donc merci de le soutenir dans
cette tâche monsieur le député vous
l'avais dit la crise aujourd'hui
touchent certains secteurs de l'est var
de l'élevage
elle est très importante dans nos
territoires parce qu'elle représente
effectivement un élément majeur de notre
économie et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs le
gouvernement s'est engagé d'une façon
permanente et très actif d'abord dans
l'évolution de la pac
parce que nous avons besoin d'une
agriculture d'élevage moderne il y a
aujourd'hui une crise une crise de
marché qui affecte les prix
effectivement mais elle est aussi le
résultat d'une politique de filières qui
ont été insuffisamment organisé et
insuffisamment investi
l'élevage jouent à je refais le pur
asseyez vous nous aviez place une
politique d'allègements de charges une
politique de relance de l'investissement
une politique active je le disais à
l'exportation nous ce crochet en ce cas
logo ont été en france de façon à
reconquérir des parts de marché en
france et à l'extérieur y compris au
sein européens et nous avons agi sur les
différents acteurs pour qu'il y ait une
remontée progressive des prix du porc et
du boeuf
même si aujourd'hui sont ces résultats
sont encore inégaux sur le territoire
mais sur lesquelles nous nous mobilisons
et les préfets également monsieur le
député vous auriez pu signaler dans
votre question
les responsabilités de la loi lme qui a
donné le fima la grande distribution et
qui a fait que notre élevage cisco ne
vienne dans la situation de parole vous
prétendez l'énoncé là